so now it just makes kamalahara seem so
insignificant
this whole debate thing it's like we
have this debate that's like i
i love talking about god but i'm down to
talk about the debate the fly
what do you want to do let's talk about
the fly all right well yeah let's talk
about the fly
the fly so there's like a viral photo of
trump and hillary and they have flies on
their faces too and obama yeah
yeah and obama they have video of obama
killing the fly with his bare hand too
whoa what yeah everybody was like yeah
and i was like someone should someone
should make a video where uh
kamala has like a lizard tongue which oh
no i actually have that meme on my phone
oh really yeah somebody somebody sent it
to me a couple hours
blizzard people she's a lizard in her
tongue dude i love his head
i love the lizard people conspiracy
theory because it was based on the fact
that internet video was bad
for real like they were like they were
old videos on youtube where they were
like
look at this video watch right here and
they would play it
right there you can see hillary
transform into a lizard and it was
artifacting
when like the video quality just goes
bad and like and i'm like dude you're
watching a flash video it's the year is
2005. calm down
i have a theory on the lizard people
they're actually lizards and they live
underground well
i think you're back in the day when
whatever humanity split and a bunch of
people went north
and to the to the tundra and they
couldn't grow crops anymore so they had
to start hunting
and in order to hunt they acted all
lizard-like
act like wild like there's crazy
bloodthirsty there's no evolution in the
past five thousand years
into lizards and so they had to hunt all
the time and they hunted and then they
came back south
and they killed and this is like the
white people basically no
no no and so they're accessing their
lizard brain
to kill the actual killer actual
conspiracy theory is that there is a
super intelligent species of dinosaur
that fled underground when the meteor
hit the earth hollow earth
it's not hollow they live in caves and
so they were very smart
so they started developing subterranean
civilizations that have been around for
millions of years longer than humanity
it's not a hollow earth it's just
literally like underground
and so then now that they're
subterranean they can't go
they've they they're too light-sensitive
so they can't leave underground
so they created the denver airport which
was moved so they could have
that's that's the whole conspiracy and
then you know
dude it's just these stories are
fascinating and fun but just
you you'd wish for them to be true just
so life would be exciting that's what i
think most
most of it is life is boring it's
routine donald trump is president i
guess everyone's satisfied for the time
being and all these weird conspiracies
have kind of gone away
but it's just not real the iron sky
sequel is about the lizard people
the lizard people it's it's ridiculous
is that the one where the nazis went to
the moon yeah but this is a sequel
and the sequel is about the the
underground lizard people oh
it's all like the politicians and stuff
oh my gosh okay great i gotta look it up
now now now it just feels like can we
we're gonna talk about the debate but
yeah just like
let's talk about magnetics that's the
real magic
similar talking about talking about mike
pence arguing with kamal hara seems so
so insignificant now what was the time
with the lizard people
let's talk about the debate come on do
you guys think one okay obviously
there's no winner or loser
oh there's a winner oh yeah there's a
winner i loved him i thought he was
great he was normal he was presidential
he was just like
classic presidential debate like it was
i loved it
yeah normalcy i yes
can who who told hillary clinton and
kamala harris that the appropriate thing
to do would be to
smile widely and massive smile
and laugh when asked serious questions
they're condescending and
they learn nothing from 2016 obviously
it's infuriating
when when someone's like we had 380 000
people
die due to the failures of the va and
that was under biden
someone tweeted at me that she was like
a hr manager and i was like yeah
yeah queen hr manager i feel i think she
hates biden man
i think that's what oh dude she hates
she hates him and hates what she's doing
and
like faking look the most important
thing to know is that everything she
if if i was pence and like someone was
interviewing me and they were like
well you know in your discussion kamala
harris said you know x y and z i'd say
well as you know it was a debate and
that means everything she said
was completely irrelevant because yeah
it was a debate indeed it was a debate
and
therefore she doesn't mean anything she
says yeah
because it was a debate yeah i thought
you were right when you said that at the
end he was very nice
when he responded to that girl it was so
sincere i loved it
and then who wait which girl the the
write-in question oh right right
student the eighth grader what was the
name what was her name i forgot
breckenridge or something
yeah but he he remembered the name and
he was bringing he kept
saying her name and like it was very
personal and it was very sincere and off
the cuff
and then kamala did hers and she was
just like vote biden
did you know that if you divide 2020 by
666 you get 303 30.
we crunch the numbers it's true that's
what someone someone super chatted that
oh that's what you text
to joe biden yeah yeah it's like a text
number
do you think it's all uh a magnetic no
no no no no no it's all connected
i refuse i think it is i just you know i
gotta be honest man
uh i think the debate was totally
meaningless it's like all these debates
are
are people like my guy won
no my guy won i liked it and i think
that
it was a nice contrast to
you have trump who's a madman and
throwing red meat to his base and being
fiery and funny
and then you had pence who was serious
and classic
and it was like a timeless
debate like it was he he held himself
well
he he was polite and i thought that it
was a nice change of pace from the
politics that we see which is constantly
mud slinging and
like um just so aggressive
i felt like we went to a time machine
yeah to like the 90s
comforting it was like like a comfort
blanket
harris isn't kamala harris is not a
return to normal no
she is a intersectionality racism
far left all of these things and mike
pence is your boring old traditional
conservative
yeah but i think that a lot of people
like
seeing that i know things have gotten so
crazy we have a freaking plague
and riots and all this insanity this
year and then you have pence who comes
and he's very reassuring he's very
positive his message was uplifting
and i think that's a nice thing for
people to see i think people
underestimate
these politicos how important showing
strength is
in terms of who gets elected so for mike
pence to be like i'm not gonna stop
talking no matter who's yelling at me
and i'm just gonna keep saying whatever
i want and talk to the hand
it showed that he pence doesn't back
down
yeah but he did it in a way that was
graceful whereas kamala was like i'm
speaking i am speaking and she's like
rehearsed
like so scripted it was just so over the
top aggressive like she was trying to
create a meme
she wanted to be like a scripted
moment it was totally planned i'm
speaking yeah
i'm speaking yeah she wanted to be a gif
right right right whatever
you know but this i got this is the
problem i think we need a mix of trump
and pence
yeah i think cause i want someone who's
going to be like oh
oh you're speaking did your did your
speech writer you know plan that one for
you is this part of your your bit
i cannot oh what's that oh someone made
it someone made a meme already
congratulations
rick rick of rick and morty oh rick
sanchez yeah man
yeah uh some some quick wit i'm just
sick of the fake
you know and i i think mike pence
brought normalcy back
he's calm rational he thanked you know
kamala for her kind words on on
the president's health and congratulated
her for you know making it where she did
and all that stuff and it was
very very straight-laced traditional
american politicians that's classic
yeah but i i i just can't we get a
little a little bit more but not too
much
into trump space you know what i mean so
you know who i thought i was thinking
would have been perfect with somebody
like tulsi because one of the things
that i've thought for a really long time
about her is that even though i disagree
with a lot of her policies
i always thought that you would be able
to sit down with her and talk to her
about something that you disagreed with
her on and you would end up probably
agreeing to disagree
but then she would take your she would
take your opinion under advisement and
be like okay i kind of see where you're
coming i
love her i do too i was like i think
that's the perfect tip i want
her and massey to have a bipartisan
ticket in 2024
and i will do i will like quit my job to
campaign for it
that'd be awesome not really sorry
you've talked a lot about massey what is
he what's his deal i don't know much
about him he's great he's just
he's uh almost like a rand paul
kind of figure except he's also
pro wikileaks him and tulsi have a
bill in there right now condemning the
arrest of julian assange
he's always speaking about like
individual liberty he came out and
defended kyle right in house which was
very bold wow
um i just i think he's great he's my
he's
in my top three right now yeah i have a
crazy idea for trump
you see you see that kind of like tie
right he went on about indicting obama
and everything he was he was being
interviewed and he was like what's bill
bart doing i i'm like we've got all this
evidence and all this information
make some arrests and bill barr's like
no we need more it's going to be better
we got bigger fish to fry
trump just pardoned assange and snowden
you know
just like there you go that'll that'll
piss him off i mean i've been saying
this for years but
who are his biggest enemies the deep
state and the fake news
if he wants to stick it to the fake news
and to the deep state
all at once pardon assange there's
nobody that the media hates more than
a truth teller who brings the receipts
and shows people actual documents
nothing that he's said has ever had to
be retracted or corrected
um and he's he's been fighting the same
people who tried to take trump down
like his that's his entire i mean i'm
not even saying that i'm just saying
like
trump if you're getting antsy and you're
getting angry because you you know you
want
you want karmic justice we'll call it
that then pardon assange and snowden i
and i will i have told people this for
years too if he pardons julian assange i
will go and get a trump tattoo in
livestreams
you've got the likes of you know glenn
greenwald and many other anti-war
leftists
who still refuse to acknowledge that
trump has given them some things
yeah so the middle eastern peace deals
with drawing troops it's like not good
enough for any of these people
glenn greenwald i think you know crop
dusts it he gets close as possible to
being like you know this is pretty good
of trump but he can't because the
intercept is still like orange man bad
yeah he goes on tucker and stuff though
and has nice conversations
i think the rest of his organization
though is just tds
like these stupid articles that they're
like it's just it's the same garbage
you'll read any of these lefty
publications
i think they should just go all in and
be like the establishment democrats
are awful warmongers imperialists and
the never trumpers who joined them are
the refugees of the of the former
republican party that trump took over
that's the other thing kamala did last
night that drove me crazy
she uh she was bragging about having all
these bushies backing her
oh yeah yeah we were like when i was on
the left
if a candidate had said this stuff as
like a bragging right
i would have been like bye i am done i
would have i would have walked out the
door and been like all right what's up
people party seriously i think uh i
think it's possible trump loses
but i think it's impossible that uh the
establishment wins in 2024
unless of course they ban everyone from
youtube facebook and twitter
i think buddha judge has a shot i don't
like him at all me neither
i immediately got bad vibes because bill
crystal's new
blog um came out and like
they were publishing tons of puff pieces
about him and i was like oh god he's
he's a closet neocon like this is the
only explanation for bill crystal's
website yeah going this hard for it's
because the
candidate the neocons in the
establishment
establishment republican party ran with
their tails between their legs when
trump took over and it wasn't supposed
to happen
and they banged on the door of the
democrats saying you know us we're
friends and the neighborhood's like oh
you poor things come inside and now they
got all of them lined up
all aligned i love it when when they
announced that you know joe biden was
getting endorsed by all these
these republicans and like intelligence
assets like i'm sorry intelligence
agents and i'm like this is the greatest
endorsement for donald trump i've ever
seen
yeah i don't like these people like
i don't understand how the the activists
left from 10 years ago were like the
fbi's you know unconstitutional
the nsa worthless wiretapping and all
these awful things and now they're like
woo
go fbi yeah it's like
now i'll be fair when it comes to the
fbi arresting like these wing nuts and
stuff
like i give prizes what prices do i'm
just saying how can the left be so antis
like anti-intelligence agency and
anti-government and now
seeing all the prices for all these
people and then they're like but trump
is the government it's like
trump is one guy in in in the office of
the president and he's got every single
one else against him
and you know i just
they these people have uh they're acting
on pure raw emotion
they have nothing behind what their
ideas actually are
and so i don't know what else can you do
so i so basically all the bush the war
mongers i don't know okay so apparently
there's a deep state and there's a
shadow government and they're two
different things i've been listening to
this kevin g
kevin ship i think is his name is the
cia shadow government yeah there's a
thing called the shadow government
and the thing called the cia and they're
the ici
the deep state i know about that one
one's an american thing and then the
other one's like a global
organization i don't believe any of that
i was according to the cia guy and he's
like
they're everywhere they know everything
they do everything if you wonder what's
going on it's this
the deep state is just a reference to
the fact that if like bill clinton
appoints someone to run the fbi
that person stays in that job typically
through multiple presidencies
right they're unelected yeah they're
unelected
people working in government who have
control and
stay there so i can't remember who it
was but it was actually
one of the heads of these intelligence
agencies says like we don't call it the
deep state we just call it permanent
government
so bush's deep state just basically was
still there when obama came in and then
they just got their tentacles into obama
and then like obama obama fired a ton of
people and brought in
you know like loyalists and stuff yeah i
remember the exact number that he fired
but like no one cared the media was like
oh we don't care
like all the anti-war stuff stopped and
obama won because they were like that's
it pack it in we won
you know we never cared in the first
place so you know and they just kicked
up their spying organ like
clapper lying under oath yeah i know to
this day drives me nuts that he
didn't get any current did you you did
for that you see trump retweet that meme
of chris farley screaming for the love
of god arrest someone
yeah yeah it's like what
what what can he do he's he's relying on
bill barr and but but i'll tell you this
i really don't like the idea of an
october surprise like if bill barr waits
until the week before the election to
launch
it's like a wave of indictments i'm
going to roll my eyes and be like
i'll still be happy to see people
indicted i want to see some like heads
roll
i mean yeah i'm like you guys want to
cry let's give you something to cry
about i don't care who it is
throw someone in jail for but for what
for what specifically
anything i just want to say hillary
clinton was caught with a with an ounce
of pot
yes straight to jail because we've had a
bunch of trump people getting screwed
they're going to jail they're losing
their houses flynn roger stone all these
people
i don't care who it is i want one of
these people to be thrown in jail
i want them to throw away the keys i
don't care because they were speeding on
the highway
like i just want one of them thrown in
jail so we can say haha we got one of
yours
don't care what did did hillary actually
break the law
do you know oh yeah yeah yeah i would
like to see her on trial well well hold
on hold on
she's very she's very clever about how
things went down and so i i
first let me just say deleting the
emails of
erasing public records smashing cell
phones and stuff
technically those were other people who
did all that
and she feigns ignorance so there's
there's i think
if you if there was a proper
investigation of her you'd
be able to get her on tons of crimes
that's my personal opinion i mean you
look at the
clinton foundation like all this money
that was coming in how is that
allowed like i'm gonna i'm gonna be in
this i'm gonna be a secretary of state
and i'm gonna launch a nonprofit that
takes money from foreign governments
like i don't care what you do with the
money
i don't care if you're using it to build
houses for the homeless working in
government while having a non-profit
takes money from other governments is
insane right yeah
dude i'm kind of getting mixed feelings
like the french revolution they just
started
chopping people's heads off yes
20 people a day they'd march them into
the center of paris and
beat the drums and it was like terrible
thing in the whole world is a woman
outside the steel and she's holding up
the sword and she's ready to cut some
heads all the way yeah but you know
we don't we don't want to know that i
don't want that no i don't want it i'm
just saying that
that was the one cool thing the french
did i i'm not a fan of the french no i
don't i don't think it was cool
i i understand the idea of overthrowing
a tyrannical government on stuff
i would i would actually say the one
cool thing is when the americans
said f your government we got our own do
something about it
and then told the f off and won i don't
like the french revolution because the
french revolution was like random people
mob justice running around chopping off
random heads yeah that kind of devolved
into that the american revolution was
straight up on pikes and walk them
through town that's kind of cool
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you